bienvenidos de nuevo en esta ocasión yo
quiero analizar la anti derivada o la
integral definida como el área bajo una
curva para ello en este vídeo voy a
utilizar mucho de su intuición y es
necesario que nosotros veamos primero un
ejemplo de física para que esto sea
mucho más ameno y aunque esto no es una
clase de física voy a jugar con
conceptos como velocidad distancia y
tiempo y además de todo esto voy a
recordarles lo que es la derivada y cómo
se aplicaba la derivada en ejemplos de
la vida cotidiana pero bueno empecemos a
trabajar en el problema del día de hoy
supongamos que la distancia base a una
función del tiempo mi distancia va a ser
la función 16 veces t cuadrada s va a
ser de distancia no sé por qué a
distancia no le ponen de no lo menos y
ya sé ya sé no le ponen de por qué se
confundiría con derivada por lo tanto
las distancias lo denotan con una s bien
ya tengo distancia con una s y te va a
ser nuestro tiempo y con esto yo ya
tengo a la distancia descrita por
cualquier tiempo supongamos que nosotros
quisiéramos saber cuánta distancia ha
recorrido en nuestro móvil
en 4 segundos pues entonces solamente
tendremos que sustituir el 4 en lugar de
la t4 de cuadrados 16 y 16 por 16 256 en
cuatro segundos el móvil habría
recorrido 256 unidades de distancia bien
vamos a graficar lo esta va a ser mi
hija de las 10 qué mal pulso tengo
parece que toma mucho café me salió una
línea horrible entonces voy a hacer lo
mejor con la herramienta de líneas esta
va a ser miren qué diferencia de leyes
pero pero empecé yo lo voy a borrar otra
vez porque solamente voy a hacerlo con
tiempo positivo sólo te tenemos el
sentido con un tiempo positivo por lo
tanto aquí es también el ay es este eje
ahora si me quedo un poco más derecho y
esta va a ser mi eje de las x bien y si
nosotros calificamos esta función nos
vamos a dar cuenta que es siempre
sencillamente una parábola entonces voy
a graficar aquí mi parábola recuerden
que no tiene sentido para tiempos
negativos y además si se dan cuenta esta
parábola pasa por el origen y cada vez
que nosotros aumentemos el tiempo esta
parábola va a ir creciendo más y más y
más su distancia
va obteniendo una aceleración esta es mi
eje de las 10 que le voy a poner mi eje
de la distancia y esta es mi eje de asx
o sea mi eje del tiempo bien ya tengo mi
palabra entonces qué va a pasar ahora si
yo quisiera calcular la velocidad que
tiene este móvil pues bien la velocidad
de existencia entre tiempo pero esa
sería mi velocidad total no mi velocidad
instantánea si yo quisiera calcular mi
velocidad instantánea necesito tener un
cambio instantáneo y para eso ocupamos
la derivada se acuerdan en algún vídeo
de aplicación de la derivada nosotros
observamos que si queríamos obtener la
velocidad instantánea es decir la
velocidad en cualquiera de nuestros
puntos de nuestra gráfica necesito
calcular la primera derivada de la
distancia con respecto al tiempo
establecer mi velocidad instantánea
entonces la derivada de s con respecto
al tiempo pues hay que derivar la
función es bajamos el exponente 32 t a
la 2 menos uno o sea 1
es mi velocidad ya tengo mi velocidad
instantánea entonces voy a escribirlo
aquí desde velocidad es igual a
velocidad muy bien ya tengo una función
que tiene que ver con mi distancia y
esta función es respecto al tiempo y ya
tengo una función que tenga que ver con
mi velocidad que también es una función
con respecto al tiempo entonces vamos a
graficar la este va a ser mi eje de mi
velocidad ni de las 10 y este va a ser
mi eje del tiempo mi eje de las equis y
se dan cuenta es una gráfica muy
sencilla 32 t es ni más ni menos que una
recta pero una recta muy empinada
así que dibujemos la base de color rojo
y la voy a tratar de dibujar lo más
empinada que puedan y que a su vez se
vea entonces voy a decir que ésta es muy
gráfica bien aquí la voy a poner y
entonces para no confundirnos voy a
poner quién es ni gráfica de que esta es
mi gráfica de la velocidad con respecto
al tiempo la voy a poner con una flecha
para no confundirnos y esta otra es muy
gráfica de la distancia con respecto al
tiempo también le voy a poner una
pequeña flecha
en algún momento voy a hacer un vídeo
acerca de las aplicaciones del cálculo
en la física pero aquí lo más importante
lo que quiero que vean es que la
distancia cuando yo la derivó con
respecto al tiempo porque la distancia
es una función del tiempo siguió la
deriva con respecto al tiempo voy a
obtener la velocidad y bueno en este
caso nosotros vemos que los dos gráficos
empezaron en cero pero la velocidad
puede empezar en cualquier tiempo y la
distancia puede empezar también en
cualquier tiempo no forzosamente tienen
que empezar en el cero de hecho el
tiempo puede empezar en cualquier
constante pero aquí lo más importante es
lo que no quiero que olviden es que si
yo derivó la distancia con respecto al
tiempo obtengo la velocidad y si yo anti
derivó la velocidad con respecto al
tiempo voy a obtener la distancia
mantener solamente va a ser importante
ahora supongamos que solamente me dan
esta gráfica no tengo nada más que esta
gráfica y me dicen que esa gráfica de la
velocidad como puedo yo obtener si
solamente tengo esta gráfica la
distancia que ha recorrido mi móvil en
un tiempo t a lo que voy es supongamos
que yo no sé que la anti derivada de la
velocidad es la distancia y solamente
tenemos esta gráfica y esta función
es la pregunta va a ser cómo podemos
saber cuál es la distancia en cualquier
tiempo bueno para contestar esta
pregunta lo primero que quiero que
analicemos es esta gráfica supongamos
que yo tengo un intervalo pequeño de
tiempo muy muy muy pequeño de tiempo tan
pequeño que es casi instantáneo entonces
a este pequeño intervalo de tiempo le
voy a llamar delta de t
esta delta de te lo voy a dibujar aquí
voy a tener un pequeño intervalo de
tiempo que va a ser este y es un
intervalo muy pequeño y lo voy a llamar
dt en lugar desde este de t para ser más
congruentes con todo lo que vamos a ver
después ya cambie de color al color rosa
porque es cuando rojo es un poco
sangriento bien ahora supongamos que yo
quiero despejar a la distancia de mi
fórmula habitual de velocidad
velocidades distancia entre tiempo
entonces la distancia es velocidad por
tiempo este despeje va a ser muy
importante unos segundos después pero
antes quiero ver una cosa si yo
sustituyo dt en mi fórmula de velocidad
es decir 32 x dt voy a obtener un valor
constante porque es un cambio constante
entonces voy a obtener un valor
constante velocidad
a esta altura yo la obtengo aplicando dt
a mi función velocidad bien si ya tengo
cuál es este rectángulo que voy a
dibujar aquí no voy a poner más fuerte
porque este retén te va a ser muy
importante y es que este rectángulo que
tengo aquí es el alma de este vídeo
porque este rectángulo es ni más ni
menos que la distancia que yo obtengo en
un instante muy pequeño por qué digo
esto
supongamos que yo quiero sacar el área
de este rectángulo quién sería pues
sería el ancho del rectángulo que es dt
por la altura del rectángulo que es la
velocidad es decir tendré algo de la
forma velocidad por tiempo que eso era
ni más ni menos que distancia sí exacto
yo acabo de sacar el área de este
rectángulo que es el ancho por el largo
el ancho que es dt y el largo que es la
velocidad que habíamos obtenido al
sustituir
dt en nuestra fórmula de velocidad y
obtengo yo ni más ni menos que la
distancia recuerden que la distancia era
según lo que despejamos la velocidad por
el tiempo bueno y con todo esto ya
solucionamos el problema del
esta columna es decir es la distancia en
este intervalo pequeño muy pequeño ahora
qué pasa si nosotros queremos todo un
intervalo más grande es decir un
intervalo que llegue hasta esta te
estate como trate especial le voy a
poner t sub índice 0 t 0
entonces yo quiero saber qué va a pasar
con mi distancia en todo todo todo este
intervalo bueno pues siguiendo la lógica
que tenemos hasta ahorita podremos
llenar todo este intervalo de
rectángulos que tengan que ver con de t
puede obtener esta columna esta otra
columna este otro rectángulo este otro
rectángulo este otro rectángulo todos
todos todos todos hasta llegar hasta el
final hasta el principio porque pues
porque si nosotros tenemos que la
distancia es el área de uno de esos
rectángulos en un intervalo dado pues
bueno si yo sumo todos mis rectángulos
obtendría una aproximación a mi
distancia que yo quiero obtener ahora
supongamos que yo pongo más y más y más
rectángulos qué quiere decir eso que mi
intervalo llego cada vez más y más y más
pequeño
estoy haciendo un intervalo más pequeño
entonces esta aproximación va a
acercarse cada vez más a la distancia
que yo quiero obtener aquí voy con todo
esto esta noción es muy importante entre
más sobre este ángulo yo tenga en este
intervalo de 0 a 0
voy a ir obteniendo cada vez una mejor
aproximación esta emoción va a ser muy
importante para lo que vamos a ver
después pero como este vídeo ya se está
haciendo muy largo y estoy acercando a
los 10 minutos lo mejor va a ser que
pause este vídeo aquí y lo continúe en
el siguiente así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo